Zoe, thank you so much for being
on my show 20 minute leaders
I cannot believe I have you on this show
this is amazing
thank you for having me
that's great
so, disclaimer
your son is one of my best friends
and a huge inspiration for me
all the way back from high school,
we met on the Playa at Burning Man
I believe it was 2014 when he
graciously invited my father
and I go to your wonderful camp, which has
evolved so beautifully over the years
we joined you at three time radio
and head life changing
experiences at Burning Man
but while you're a burner and you're all
competing in the world,
in the global scavenger hunt,
actually competing your winning
the global scavenger hunt
more so competing
a you're actually a pretty incredible
litigator and you're fighting
for some really important causes
Zoe, who are you?
once and for all, clear this
up for me, who are you?
I think I'm a person like
most people that are
working hard in their
profession is I'm a lot of things
you know, I'm a mom
I'm definitely a burner
I definitely am addicted to adventure travel
and I had the great fortune of choosing
a career that I love and that has always
brought me great joy and
frustrations and successes and failures
but I think if you start off on a track
that you know you love,
you're never going to
be bored or disappointed
wonderful, you know, I mean,
the Jewish Mom tradition that we know
is that, yeah you can be a Doctor or a lawyer
regardless if you could or not
but you're a lawyer that you'll love,
you're doing
you're litigating
why do you love it so much
what is it about
it excites you?
when I was a little girl,
I knew that I had an inherent talent, that
I was not afraid of speaking in public
and most people are terrified
of speaking in public
so it's sort of like a superpower
the number one fear in the world
yes, it's a superpower if
you're not afraid of it
and I realize I like speaking in public
and I wasn't afraid of it
and there was only a few professions
that pay you to speak in public
politician, lawyer
and so very young
I realized I wanted to litigate because
that was a way to get paid,
to do what I liked and what I
had an inherent talent for for
well, you could have also gone to L.A
and Hollywood and go on Broadway
but you chose to be in the courtroom
but the courtroom is
theater in its own way.
if you are not entertaining and persuading
and keeping the jurors attention
you're not winning
I love it
ok, so so litigator, lawyer
and what type of lawyer are you?
because you get to deal
with some really crazy cases
It's not just this, you know, these
ordinary cases that we hear about on TV
I have been lucky in that I never had
to do sort of entry level legal work
of car accidents and slip and falls
I got into a practice early on that did
big cases and then I formed my own firm
and I've always had my choice of cases
so I got to choose
the people I represented
I've always represented people injured
by the negligent or gross negligent
conduct of corporations and other people
and I have had great the honor of speaking
for people whose lives have been destroyed
by the negligence of others
and that is as a true honor
you know that that's insane because
it's not just about somebody life's
being ... and then going for them
and speaking out about it
but you're actually tackling
some huge corporation,
hundreds of billions of dollars or
a hundred million dollars who have,
you know, in comparison to the resources
that the individual has
It's uncomfortable and here
you come saying well, we're the underdogs,
I'm going to represent you and we are going to be
better than than the dozen
lawyers that they're putting up
but how fun is that is to choose
a profession where the people you're
against are the best money can buy
I go against the most powerful and
well-funded corporations,
and they can afford the best lawyers
which means you're always going against
people who make you up your game
and be the top of your game
yeah, so I'm I'm not sure you can disclose this
but is there like one case of one example
of a case that has been public disclosure
that you can just mention what type
of just to give a context of what types
of cases the art you're tackling
yeah
so for a long time,
I represented women who had developed
breast cancer from taking a defective
drug, a hormone therapy
drug and menopause
and there were women who should
never have had breast cancer
their family had should never
have gone through that experience
some of them had died from the breast cancer
and it was really rewarding
they were older women who had been very
trusting of the drug industry,
really trusting that the pharmaceuticals
they were taking were really just going
to be beneficial and not hurt them
and then they got this terrible diagnosis
and went through years
of treatment and fear
and so representing them and getting
justice for them and their
family was incredible
and it was against both Wyeth and Pfizer,
two of the largest companies in the world
unbelievable
so so paint me a picture as you're standing
there in the courtroom and you have a
and you have a jury and and you're talking
about, you know, these
are emotional subjects
people's lives are being ruined
how do you even go about approaching
a case like this when you're saying, like,
wow, I have to deal
with with Pfizer and why it's
I think you have to come from a place
of gratitude that your client has has
gifted you this opportunity
to speak for them
my clients either are dead or sick
they can't understand the concepts
of a courtroom and they need
someone to advocate for them
so being a litigator is truly
an honor of being an advocate
you get to tell their story
you get to show the jury what they went
through with the decisions that were made
at the corporate level that
were decisions that ended up really
hurting this family and this person
and once you come from that part,
then you speak with authentic passion,
because I truly believe in the
In the veracity of my client's case,
I believe in what they're trying to do
and then I speak from my heart
and once you are passionately trying
to get that message across,
the juries will listen
Zoe, that's beautiful
and I have to say that while you're
explaining I, I, I don't know that side of you
in court because I know the
At Burning Man and, you know,
going to going and eating dinner together
out outside of burning
but, you know, the side that I also see
is that you're bringing this heart
and passion for your personal life
I mean, I'm meeting these people that are
joining our camp at Burning Man whose lives
you've literally transformed
and they have so much gratitude
for what you've given them
and I know you're too humble to come
and say, yeah, I did that
but but it but it's true
and I speak also personally
and there's like Zoe
did this for me
It's The Burning Man
but my whole life and I think just
it's remarkable and it just shines
and you've been an inspiration for me over
these past six years that I've had that
I've had the privilege of knowing you
but you're also so adventurous
out of the courtroom
talk to me a little bit about this,
this burner within you
what is it about burning
now that attracted you so much?
I think if you haven't been to Burning Man,
then it's hard to put it into words
but there is a impossible yeah,
there is a core to Burning Man,
which is a belief that together we can be
better, that if we have each other's back,
if we go into the desert with no water
and electricity and you can't buy or sell
anything, you have to rely on each other
to survive and to have fun
and it's hard fun, you know, your hot
you don't have air conditioning hard fun
it's hard fun
but if you can do that,
if you can really embrace the the
sense of community and to be together,
we are better
then Burning Man is a transformational
experience as you feel
the Zen of that community
definitely
and so just to paint a picture
of the Burning Man project is
a seven or eight days where we go
into the desert to fly a black rock city
about three hours into the Nevada desert
and we form a community of about 70 or 80
thousand individuals that are becoming
a family and sort of like a total
in mindset and, you know,
one of the things that I also spoke about
this with my father extensively the first
time we came you,
you ride your bike down down the street
that you create and there's not a single
piece of trash on the hole
and you just think to your self
wow
there's so much junk
that everybody is bringing in
and and, you know, the fight that you
have to take everything out with you
and because of this social responsibility,
we community, we keep it clean
and we keep the same values
I think that's just incredible
and the world can learn so
much from this project
I agree
and, you know, what we learn is that if we
have to rely on each other,
we all have to uphold that societal bond
we have to take care of ourselves
we have to take care of our own trash
we can't leave other people
to pick up our leftovers
you know, we have to work together
and that is the sense
that's the essence of Burning Man
definitely
ok
and so we're going to leave time and talk
about the Athena project that
that you just started
but before that,
you are competing in one of the world's
craziest adventures,
the global scavenger hunt, which is
the number one on my bucket list to do
and you're not you're not only
competing, you're winning it
It's almost every time
that you participate
tell me about this global scavenger hunt,
everything
and you go around the world
and do these crazy experiences
it's a wonderful nonprofit
that raises money for charity
and it's put on by an inspired couple
who really believe that the way for people
to appreciate being global citizens
is to see the world in a new way
and so it's a blind date with the world
you don't know where you're going
you don't know how long
you're going to spend there
you don't know what you're gonna
have to do when you get there
and you basically blindly
take this date with the world
you show up in some
place on the West Coast
and for the next twenty three days,
you're going to go west around the world,
circumnavigate the world
you're going to stop in 11,
12, 13 countries each time you land
wow
and I know you don't know which ones
you get one small suitcase
so you have to sort of pack layers because
you don't know if you're
going cold or hot
and when you land in each country,
the producer of the event gives you
a booklet of challenges, scavenges,
puzzles, things you have to discover,
decipher, clues you have to use
you cannot use any electronics,
which is so scary because we're
used to Googling everything
you cannot use any electronics
yes,
you cannot use any electronic maps
you have to walk out of the hotel and just
stop people and start interacting
in whatever country you are using
charades because you don't speak
the language and have locals
from that country help you
decipher these scavenges and point you
in the right direction and get you
to the places you need to go
to make the points and in each country
the person who does the most makes
the most points and wins that leg
and then if you win enough legs,
then you become first,
second or third in the competition
but it's all one of the flaws, of course.
of course, no
but so effectively, it's like
the amazing race without cameras
more authentic
and for a good cause for charity
and it's designed to try and make you
look at things from different group's perspective
so for one example,
we were in Cairo and obviously if you're
in Cairo, you want to go to the Sphinx
but we had to first go to the grand souk
and buy traditional African headgear
then we had to go to a camel
stable and rent camels
we had to put on the African headgear,
get on the camels ride over the dunes
and we approached the Sphinx from the
dunes on camels in African headgear
so you see that experience of approaching
the Sphinx is from a different
from a different way, a more authentic,
interesting way
and that's what he wants you to do
get out of your tourist mode,
up where we're going to eat next
what tourist attraction we're going to go
take pictures at and do something
different when we went to China
you had to run a mile
on the Great Wall of China
like you didn't just get to
go off and take your picture
you had to do something
when we went to Tiananmen Square,
you had to approach a family and get them
to agree to fly a kite with one of their
kids and take a picture of you and the kid
flying a kite in Tiananmen Square,
which means you had to interact
with people and talk to them and explain
what you were doing and ask questions and
feel like you were really appreciating
the country in a different way
so it sounds so incredible
ok
so at FEMA,
that FEMA joint project
to empower women litigators, the video
is so amazing and it's so inspiring
but tell me a little bit about what how
did this come about,
especially in times of Covid-19?
well, pandemic we're all shut in
and we just had this brainstorm of we
there are very few women
run law firms still
I know that's incredible,
but it still is true
and six very powerful women who all run
their own law firms who are really
well-respected in the in the field
decided, why don't we start pooling
our reputation and everything that we have
put together over the decades
and help other women litigators
so women who leave a law firm to start
their own shop and they
can't get a credit line
could we provide funding women who think
when they show up at mediation,
they don't have the reputation to really
get full value for their cases?
can we put our name behind them?
can we help those people brainstorm?
can we help those people
redo their trial strategies?
and one of the things we found is when
men-run, firms came to us for help getting
their trials together,
redoing their case strategies
one of the requirements was you had
to have a woman on your trial team
or we wouldn't help
so, you know, I love it, just to try to push more firms
to think always can we have a diverse
trial team? can we make sure there's
at least one woman on every trial team
to put more women in the courtroom?
I love it
so tangibly, how did this work as the six
of you, you're running your own firms
you're extremely busy with your own cases
so are you sort of like a board?
you have applicants come in and you form
relationships and you back them both with
perhaps funding, but mainly reputation
is that how it works?
yes, or we can work with them if they're
if they've got a case that they feel is
a little bit too big for them, we can
come in and help them try the case
we can work with them
we can share the funding on the case
we can share the fee on the case
we the purpose is to really
give women options
that is not really available right now
of having support, money, reputation,
experience,
and to just kind of do plus honestly
we just love working together and it's
a great opportunity for us
to work cooperatively
me and these other five women that I love
and who are so talented,
I learn every conversation we have
I learn so much about how they look
at a case or how they work on the case or
different ideas of how to really
make something more persuasive
so it's just been great fun
but I think we're also have
an opportunity to do some real good
I love it, you know,
so Zoe we just have a few minutes left
but I'd love to I'd love to pick your
brain as someone you're dedicating your
life to the community and people and to thinking
of who has wronged who
and how can we correct
this this wrongdoing?
and I'd let go
maybe 30,000 feet in the air and sort
of look at our society and hear a little
bit about, about what you think we do
as as global citizens to improve our
society and to boost the number
of of these things that are happening
it sounds very cliche, but I wonder
but I really am interested in
concerned about this
I think the most important thing is
that we have to accept
that we are global citizens
we are not Americans
we are not Texans
we are not Californians
we are global citizens in this world
everybody is connected
and maybe it's because I'm an immigrant
but I think it's really special when you
start to see your place in the world as
not just a person, but a global community
and that requires us putting down some
of our nationalism and populism and really
working together to make
the planet a better place
from global warming to climate
change to trade deals
we have got to work together
the inequality, the income
inequality is is startling
we have got to make the whole
world a more
equitable place, both in terms of the
planet and just what we do every day
and that starts with us thinking
of ourselves as a part of a very big
picture, which is this whole planet
oh, definitely
but
but you know
so it sounds like
so this is sort of a bottom up approach saying we
need to rethink our values and to intend
that we are we are global citizens
but at the end, a lot of it is also top
down where you know, where most
of us are following along
the different politicians up there or
the different leaders that that are
dictating sort of how we should
behave and how we should think
well, how tangibly can we be
can we can we tackle this?
and how do we expect, you know,
300 million people to think for themselves
and not just take for granted what what
the leaders are necessarily saying?
I think we have to come from a place
of much more kindness and loving
appreciation than we do right now
the divisiveness has got to stop
It's got to be it's we've got
to stop being different tribes
I mean, this country is
tribal and really we're all global
and we've got to get back there,
we've got to stop the divisiveness
we've got to appreciate each other,
love each other, be kind to each other
and particularly now
take care of each other
oh yeah
do the right thing so that everybody,
even the vulnerable and especially
the old are protected
and we've got to start rethinking
that and put down these
tribalism and this divisiveness
one hundred percent
now, you know, I took a course
at Stanford this year called
the Spirit of Democracy
with the world expert Larry Diamond
and one the things he's talking about,
his deterioration,
the deterioration of democracy
not just in the US, but around the world
and part of it is that we we forget
to look up and to to consider what's
actually happening around and get out
of the small bubble of that that we're
being fitted in sometimes wrongfully
and I think that's I definitely agree
kindness, empathy
I think this scavenger hunt
this sort of ability to go and meet these
different colors and flying a kite
in Tiananmen Square instead of going
and taking a picture as a tourist
that's that's definitely, I think
the right path
Zoe,
before we go, I ask you the hardest
question and I'm putting you a little bit
on the spot here, but I'd love for you to
tell me three words that best describe you
I would probably say passionate,
because I feel very strongly about my
my career and what I do for a living
I would say generous,
because I think it's very important
that people who have had gifts and had
opportunities be generous to others
don't pull the ladder up behind you,
but help other people up that ladder
I love that metaphor
And I would say spirited
because I'm a force to be reckoned
with when I put my mind
to something 100 percent
and I
I can definitely attest to that
Zoe, thank you so for the time
thank you for the inspiration
with everything that you're doing
it's really wonderful
and please send it send my regards
to your wonderful, wonderful son
thank you
and good luck to you, love